daniel's in new york city hey daniel how
are you
daniel hello hi daniel hey dave and john
what's going on how are you
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
uh thank god um so i've been a listener
for a couple years already you know i
listen daily really keeps you motivated
and moving in the right direction
thank you but um but yeah of course so i
set myself up i think i'm in a good spot
i have some money saved up
in the past couple years of working and
i wanted to know how what i can do to
really be
setting myself up for success
okay are you working you're in college
how old are you what's your story
i'm in college i have about a year left
okay what are you studying
business management good for you okay
what's it gonna cost to finish
um no i have a college fund that's
taking care of that and i have some
scholarships
as well so great what's it gonna cost to
finish
not sure exactly uh probably another
two semesters so you don't know what a
semester costs
maybe like another 25 to 50 000 here's
25 each semester where the crap are you
going to school
yeah on mars say again
it's a private university yeah i guess
that where are you going to school
in the city is it a secret
it's a secret is it a secret school
what's the name of your school
what say it again
it's not such a large school so i'd
rather not say okay
all right it's a very small very
expensive school in new york city it's a
spy school day yes
okay well it's a secret school all right
so the um
all right so uh you think you have
enough money in the college fund and in
scholarships to finish how much money do
you have saved that you're worried about
investing
uh like 250. 250
000 yeah spy school is paying pretty
good
this is pretty neat i'm way in the wrong
job i should have been what in the world
are you doing where did you get 250
000 i mean i've been working
since like all throughout high school
since i'm like 14. i worked really hard
in high school and i had like
250 dollars exactly 11. where did
you what did you do i just i never is it
a secret what you did
you were a spy in high school weren't
you and now you're in spy school
and now you're rich dude i was so
impressed we're picking on you these
numbers are bizarre
way to go well here's the thing the
standard answer here is this
and i'll stick with the standard answer
although these numbers are not standard
um congratulations you're obviously a
young stud
oh kidding aside awesome you're you've
got scholarships
you've made a lot of money already i
never saw 250 good
lord that's amazing good for you so
proud for you
so your first goal is graduate you
are the secret sauce to success graduate
with no debt you think you've got that
figured out you probably do have that
figured out you probably have enough
money in your
account with your scholarships and your
college fund to do that
i really don't care if you invest 150
000 for the next one year
that is not going to change your life
going finishing this school with zero
debt and launching yourself with zero
debt into the marketplace
is going to change your life and
understanding that you are the secret
sauce here
not the interest on 250 000 for one year
dave would you recommend a 23 year old
with that kind of money
to launching to buy a house or would you
even recommend this
out of school to chill yeah get out of
school because when you graduate from
school you have a high
rate of uh transition correct
you don't you often change cities you
obviously start a new job
a real job and the chances of changing i
know he'd probably ought to keep doing
the one he's doing but
um the uh uh and it's not unusual get
married
right in that in within 18 months of
that right so
statistically not everybody you don't
have to it's not like a rule you're not
doing something wrong if you don't
there's some there's some research that
says men especially
do everything all at once right that one
year following school
and that takes some money and you
probably are going to end up in the same
city you're in
a high statistical average you're going
to end up in her city
or is there any data on you take a job
right out of college
what's the chances you're still in that
job five years later
yeah very low okay that's what i would
think these days in the old days it was
but
these days the average person has 17
jobs in their working lifetime okay
so you got the turnover but dude you're
you've done so well daniel you're gonna
be all right i think you're gonna
struggle through with your quarter
million dollars
yeah you're gonna figure it out and if
y'all need any extra spies daniel you
know a guy
you you always wanted to be a spot i
always wanted to be a spy
well when it pays like that i'm telling
you bond in high school man
i had no idea james bond was so loaded
he drank well but man
i didn't know it was a good high school
he's had a good car but we thought it
was a government car
i made it i thought i was killing it
making 20 bucks a lawn in high school
daniel just embarrassed me man well he
said 250 i didn't know what he meant
that's quite a go danny not for you
daniel we're we're having some fun buddy
but
my only because i'm jealous yeah exactly
and we're just
freaked out but yeah you did really good
man so graduate
graduate graduate graduate graduate
debt-free then become an investor
then start your life don't get into a
bigger hurry you're not missing out on
compound interest
by being out of the market for one year
making sure you graduate
graduate graduate graduate debt-free you
are the secret sauce you are the best
investment you can make